this is a production of Cornell
University
yeah so what I'd like to do this
afternoon is go through the topics as
listed first knowing that's a fairly
broad audience I want to bring you up to
date on what about the cut flower
industry as it exists here in North
America South America perhaps a little
in Europe and then narrow down to the
North American and the state situation
to get a perhaps a little better
understanding what the industry consists
of and then the the area of support for
that industry is fairly unique so I
wanted to present you some information
on that both on the extension side as
well as the research side but on the
research side I'm going to mostly be
talking about the fun I'm having with
cut flowers or have had for the last
dozen years or so that's not to say
there isn't research going on elsewhere
but I'm just kind of selfish in that
regard so when I lecture I like to have
an open mic so everyone can participate
if there are things that aren't clear or
if you'd like to add something
feel free to pipe up I'd be glad to hear
from you the states doesn't produce much
in the way of cut flowers we rely on
primarily South America for the cut
flowers that we buy because we want to
buy them year-round to have Valentine's
Day without roses would be unheard of to
produce roses at that time of year here
is prohibitively expensive and probably
consumers wouldn't stand for it but we
have a very lively process of
importation of especially roses but also
chrysanthemums carnations and
alstroemeria from South America
especially Colombia where they can grow
year-round the labor is cheap the
transportation costs are minimal and so
as a result of that our domestic
production of those four commodities is
is really very small so we do produce
cut flowers here and some of them are
listed in the lower part of the table
and increasing percentages as you go
down of gladiola irises lilies tulips
are about half-and-half coming from
other places and even those tulips that
we do grow here the bulbs are not being
produced here they're coming from
Holland primarily Chile sometimes so
it's not really a wholly domestic
industry I guess I shouldn't wander
around too much that I could slide so
that the South America Kahn aspect is
Highland valleys near the equator
temperature the same year-round no photo
period problems and so they grow them
undercover as you can see for the mums
here and these structures here that
looks like there might be carnations
underneath so some of the high tunnels
that they have there are very extensive
some are modern and some are more
traditional protection from rain is
primarily what they want them for
because the temperature regulation is
not necessary so that's how a bulk of
flowers are produced that end up in our
market the point about those flowers yes
some of them I identified and the USDA
keeps track of how many stems are being
produced and what the value is and so on
but a lot of others like sunflowers for
instance which are a real big deal they
aren't keeping track of those dahlias is
another one which is not accounted for
you need to ask the USDA I think they
lump them under others and so it it's an
incomplete record but the quantities in
comparison to roses are sufficiently low
that they there are too many different
species I think is what what's happening
there so there are snapdragons
delphiniums lisianthus which we'll be
talking about to some extent suffice to
say that there are a bunch of different
flowers each with their cultural
practice requirements post harvest
characteristics laws life etc etc so it
gets to be a fairly complicated subject
and one that doesn't lend itself readily
to extension so large-scale production
in the u.s. of cut flowers is primarily
on the west coast because of their more
favorable climatic conditions and we
have here this is Washington Oregon
toward the coast cool somewhat cloudy
mornings then the Sun comes out the rest
of the day is fine a very regular
climate which allows a lot of different
species to be grown hydrangea here calla
lilies in this particular part of the
picture some other examples a greenhouse
production of gerberas in the
Watsonville area of Central California
large-scale mostly under glass
tulip production in this case in a
factory type of situation in Virginia
and again like I mentioned this is
production using bulbs from Holland for
some parts of the year and in other
parts of the year when Holland can't
supply they're getting them from Chile
and they're able to keep producing in
some cases hydroponically in some cases
it's just in mix for 10 out of 12 months
this time of year it's too hot in the
greenhouse so they do a poor job of it
but the rest of the time and if you go
down to Wegmans or other stores these
would be the tulips you'll be getting
okay it doesn't say so but this is a big
big outfit and there are one or two
others that do a similar sort of
production in other parts of California
are growing Hypericum over there on the
right looks like stocking the right and
scabiosa so lots of different flowers
large scale but mostly going to a
wholesale kind of marketing system when
we come closer here to the Northeast and
New York State more specifically and
there are some large scale producers and
they tend to go into the wholesale
primarily we have in fact the picture on
the upper right is one of the large
scale peony farms that existing just
north of the Experiment Station in
Geneva and there's a second peony grower
in that same vicinity this particular
one has a farm in Geneva as a farm in
Pennsylvania and a couple of farms in
Maryland and he starts harvesting in
Maryland and then works his way up so
that the relatively narrow harvesting
period for peony is extended over that
that four times harvest season these are
some pictures from Long Island dahlias
and clearly again larger scale
production close to the place where
those flowers would be in demand by far
the largest number of producers are in
fact small scale not only here but
scattered over the United States and
again it says implications as far as
extension is concerned because you're
not talking to three or four big people
you're talking to folks that are doing
it part-time
small-scale
a number of different species in fact if
you look up the book or count the number
of species listed in what we would
consider the Bible of cattle our
production that Armitage and mouse women
put together you come up with 83 species
and there are more besides that but so
there are a number of of annuals
perennials woody species geo fights
meaning bulbs and then nearly using in
many cases flowers but could be foliage
could be the fruit sticks and these
sorts of things you can look at these
later in the talk to see what specific
ones we're talking about they're mostly
locally marketed it avoids too big for
roses carnations mums alstroemeria
because they can't compete and then but
the emphasis is freshly produced hasn't
been shipped will last longer in the
bath and that's the advantage that the
local producers have and some just
pictures of those small-scale farms a
couple of them from within Tompkins
County here lots of flowers and any of
you who have gone to the iske farmers
market know that there are two very good
producers of of cut flowers that market
there so farmers markets are a favorite
place to sell the flowers that they
produce you find them in supermarkets as
well weddings and events actually the
wedding trade has become quite important
for the local producers if they're able
to deal with the wives are sorry the the
mother-in-law's that are very fussy
about what color and size etc flowers
they want the growers that can manage
that at the same time they're producing
their their crop they can succeed very
well and the prices are very good
and and that's I think in the recent
years has been a shift from going to the
florist to get the flowers to going to
the producers themselves and specifying
I'm going to get married in three months
I need this color and so on and so forth
and can be a little cheaper but not an
awful lot but that's become a quite
important one there is some roadside
trade as is shown here from a picture on
Long Island but that's relatively minor
and then bouquet subscriptions so that
restaurants say gets a bouquet or ten
bouquets to put on the tables in that
restaurant once a week or something like
that
oftentimes a regular CSA
community-supported agriculture farm
that allows people to pick or get a
share of the product if they go to the
farm themselves there are often are
picking gardens where they can cut
sinuous sunflowers glad your lights and
things like that yeah so in some cases
yeah yeah that's a good point okay so as
I've hinted all along the information
for on cut flowers is difficult because
there are so many species and because
there are so many producers and they're
relatively few organizations that can
cater to that so Cornell Cooperative
Extension is what we go to for
information if you ask them for
information on cut flowers you don't
find very much and I think what has
happened is that they have seeded the
field to this organization here the
associate association of specialty cut
flower growers which is a national
affective even international
organization based in ohio run by an
executive director and
one or two staff was founded about 25
years ago and they have a number of
services that cater very well to these
diverse people that are growing a number
of different crops they publish a
quarterly magazine on some folks in this
room please and Bill myself etc have
written articles about some of the
research that's going on in cut flower
work as part of that they have regional
meetings and annual meetings depending
on the earth dotted all over the u.s. in
Canada as well so those can be quite
important but what's even more important
is a listserv and that's really the
Extension Service that provides
information and it's essentially growers
helping other growers because there are
so many different species you type in
there and say I need some information on
distil is the antis variety within a day
someone else said oh yeah I tried that
one stinks so that's the end of that
right or there could be long discussions
about some topic about bed shapers or
ways of planting seedlings etc etc and
it's amazing there are some of the older
members who are part of this
organization who have been very
participatory and have provided
tremendous help to new people no it's
not for free the organization although
is non-profit it does require about $200
a year for people to to belong to that
but if you as a grower find some
information that helps you market your
flowers more effectively that $200 is
paid back in that one message that that
you got so it has succeeded very well
and and is thriving as I'll show you in
a minute then they also run a
coordinated coordinated variety trial
and growers who would like to
participate are sent six packets of
Xenia varieties new varieties that the
seed companies want to try and test out
in the field
and at the end of the year these growers
then have to write and say yeah this one
went fine and this Deming was this and
the diameter was that and it lasted
quite a while and I liked it but this
other one I wouldn't grow again and then
the quarterly magazine the January issue
has all these reports in summarized and
it's a very valuable piece of
information then they have a small
Research Foundation which gathers money
to give out as research grants so that
institutions like Cornell could do small
trials that help to explore particular
things then there's quite a bit of
post-harvest work going on at North
Carolina State University John Dole runs
a yearly program of testing all the new
varieties to see how long they last in
the Vosges with different editions and
so on so this is a very valuable
organization that if you are at all
interested in in cut flowers this is the
place to go and with the current
popularity of going local and doing it
yourself you can see the membership
numbers going up from around 500 or so
in 2008 and you know 2015 and it's
climbing so the organization has become
very popular and it's been a key to the
growth of that industry and they have
perhaps some interesting challenges
ahead on what should be done in the
future to keep up with the demand for
information okay so research
there's post-harvest research is one of
the most important things in John dole
at NC State as I just mentioned is the
foremost scientist studying this this
area trying to see how long can we keep
flowers alive of particular varieties
should we be putting them in water
should we putting them in some kind of
flower solution etc etc but that's his
field and I've had much more fun with
doing other things not very complicated
things and I want to tell you a bit
about that research one that we're just
concluding now for the second year is a
chance observation that snapdragons are
fairly Hardy and even in our winters
here we can have a situation where they
kind of struggle back in the second year
after you've grown them in in the first
year and so we had a variety trial in
the in our high tunnel does everyone
understand high tunnel what I mean is
essentially a greenhouse that doesn't
have heat and where we're producing the
crop in the ground not in containers so
they're up to them and we keep it
covered during the winter so there is
some protection going on in that
situation so these are experiments that
we have been doing in the high tunnel
situation and in this case also
comparing with growth in the field and
so we did a series of planting dates
trying to see how can we produce this
crop and because we can extend a season
earlier with a tunnel we were able to
sow the seed on in mid-february and we
were harvesting by the 31st of May with
the field planting we came in a couple
of weeks later or a week later
then a second tunnel planting came in
about mid-september the yields in the
first three were quite good the last one
didn't really have enough time so we
followed up on this work a couple of
years ago we had a variety trial in the
high tunnel where we were looking at
just performance of the varieties and
then at the end of that fall season the
plants looked so good I thought well
let's just see if they can survive over
the winter and lo and behold some of
them did quite well and came back and we
harvested the second crop so you can see
the yields here and this is yield per
unit area for the first one Chantilly
the yield went down a little bit the
next one did fine in the fall but then
it was mostly winter killed there wasn't
anything left nothing came back so the
yield was essentially fallen that said
so this was a problem of winter damage
now we didn't do anything extra we
didn't put any extra protection on these
they were just surviving or not as the
case may be and you can look down the
rest of the list and see that some did
fine and some of them this Potomac
lavender in fact gave higher yields in
the spring than it did in the fall
before but it showed that yes you can
overwinter this crop and that might be
something that a grower in our region
would do so we followed up on that this
past year with a more regular experiment
where we again sowed the seed in the
fall and our sorry in the summer for the
fall harvest and then kept the plants
over until the spring but protected them
in different ways and that result showed
first of all that again we could see
varietal differences in winter survival
but we also could make quite a bit of
difference in winter survival by keeping
a low tunnel over the plants themselves
so we harvested the fall crop there
wasn't much left above ground but then
put
low tunnel over over that and then in
the spring as it started coming up we
kept the tunnel in place until they
started to to shoot up and lo and behold
with that low tunnel protection we got
quite a nice yield in the spring so a
combination of having the right variety
and protection actually gets you around
40 stems per square foot which on a 9 by
9 inch spacing is not too shabby I think
in fact we stopped harvesting this
experiment we got sick of it and we had
so many other things that we were doing
in the spring that they kept on growing
and right and we could have gotten more
stems off this thing but decided to stop
it's really hard to define annual I
think in this situation it's you know it
depends what kind of Windows you have I
think in a zone 7 probably a perennial
unless it's taken out by some disease or
something like that yeah ok so next
topic so that essentially that work
points to the fact that we can in fact
use that structure the high unheated
greenhouse as a way of perhaps having
perennials that wouldn't make it outside
do so with the help of that structure
and maybe something more than that and
so we've had a bit of experimentation
with you comas the pineapple lily bill
was Miller and his students have done
much more in that regard but we've
successfully overwintered this switch
outside well bill can do it but I
haven't been able to keep you coma
slowly alive over the
over the winter but that's one that
certainly can be experimented with
agapanthus is a is a beautiful flower
and I'd love to get some research going
on that but I'm running out of time to
do it so I'm passing the torch and then
the other one alstroemeria dr. mark
bridge and the director of the Long
Island Station is an alstroemeria
breeder and he has developed some
varieties of alstroemeria that will do
quite fine in the field but in the
tunnel environment where the stamens get
longer we might be able to really
revolutionize that crop and use it here
instead of importing it from Colombia so
there's work to be done I think it might
be quite interesting
another simple problem at simple
technique is sort of generally I'd like
to see as many stems as possible per
unit area harvested for these cut
flowers and so what I'd like to be able
to do is manipulate the plants to become
more productive and in many cases fine
you can just plant them closer together
and they all produce more stems but
plants are expensive and are there other
ways we can do this
well horticulturists and gardeners have
known for centuries that if you pinch
out the top of the plant
when it's still in its vegetative stage
you force branches from from the base so
here we've been doing this with several
species but here's sunflower it's
producing about six leaves out comes the
growing point and what you end up with
then is one two three branches where the
growing point was before and these can
get quite tall and suddenly you have a
yield three times of what you had before
it's not too bad so we've done a fair
amount of work in this especially with
sunflowers but also with other species
and I wanted to show you some of that
flowers when you do that instead of
having one stem per unit area you have
three so they have to somehow manage in
that smaller amount of space per stem
and so what happens is the stems are
thinner and the flowers are smaller
here's a comparison this is the control
which has not been pinched here it is
after pinching so they're smaller well
there's a market for those and you do
get quite a nice increase in yield
there's a comparison you can see the
back of that picture the ones that
haven't been pinched these have so
there's delayed a little bit in
flowering five six seven days but the
yield is increased and if you look at a
typical experiment this one from
nineteen or sorry 2007 where stem
numbers are increased the days to flower
are delayed a little bit the stem length
is reduced for individual stem but 60
centimeters for a stem if you had a
meter long you're gonna put that in the
vas @b area up here so you really only
need fifty or sixty centimeters so it's
not a big deal and the flower diameter
as I showed in the previous picture is
also reduced
so that's feasible and it's something
that can be easily done but as I
mentioned you do sacrifice flower flower
size and that can become a constraint if
you overdo it so we've been doing
experiments along this line for some
time and using different spacings six by
six inches nine by nine inches twelve by
twelve inches and as you see as you
crowd the plants closer and you pinch
them you see the flowers get pretty
small and you get to a point where yeah
I don't like that it's too small and
there are abnormalities that come in
miss shapen these sorts of things so the
market determines then what you can get
away with and what you can still sell
and if you express it in terms of stem
yield per unit area the more you squeeze
over to the right the more you curve
this thing down and if the market says
well this minimum size that I will
accept is around 1.5 inches then you
better not go any higher than 6,000
stems 4,000 square feet so it's that
kind of relationship within this of
course you will have differences between
varieties so the pro cut amber glow that
inverted triangle is one that has a
larger flower to start with so you
squeeze it it also reduces in size but
that line is above the line of the other
two varieties that have smaller flowers
so this relationship is something that
can be quite useful and might might be a
good guide okay so we're into pinching
let's pinch something else lisianthus
beautiful flower looks like a rose lasts
a long time in the bars you'll in the
bars back in the corner over there when
you have some more snacks you'll be able
to take a closer look now this plant
produces several stems per plant
unlike the sunflower you're already
starting with several and if you pinch
it early it will produce branches but
your increase in yield is going to be
less than what you'd expect then you'd
get with a single stem sunflower but you
still again by manipulating that the
spacing the amount of area per plant you
can again increase productivity fairly
fair amount again these are experiments
that we're doing again this year this is
last year with using two spacing six by
six and nine by nine pinching or not
our stem lengths interestingly enough at
least at the closest spacing actually
increases and what's happening here is
that the stems are closer together so
they're stretching for the light and
they're they're actually getting longer
but look at the yield per square foot 15
against 11 or the way we are had been
growing it before we're only getting
maybe nine or so and the flowering dates
are delayed a little bit by pinching but
not all that much so a combination of
close spacing and pinching is actually
giving us quite a nice increase in yield
and here are some pictures of that
unfortunately this is a six by six this
is a nine by nine that hasn't been
pinched in the same variety six by six
nine by nine with pinching you see this
stretching out this is cheating a little
bit this whole thing should be shifted
up so it isn't showing isn't giving the
whole truth but you'll have to trust me
on that
okay second last topic sunflowers may or
may not react to day length depends on
the variety and it in many cases if
you're just producing sunflowers during
the summer it doesn't really matter and
the sensitivity to this day length is
happening in the first three weeks after
emergence after that the flower has
either already formed or will be
somewhat delayed depending on the
reaction so we found in screening that
some are what we would call facultative
short day pants that means that even if
the day length is long they will
eventually come to flower or they are
day neutral and then we found a few that
are actually contrary they do it the
other way they're delayed by short days
but
by long days so we've worked with a a
screening test which allows us to grow
the plants in the greenhouse under
controlled day lengths conditions for
the first three weeks and then we
transplant them to the field and then
measure what happens and the result you
can see here with some varieties it's
quite drastic in fact if you have one
that's sensitive and give it short days
it stays small it flowers three weeks
earlier and then the one that's growing
under long day and some other
characteristics change as well if you
look at it closely and one of the
varieties that is most sensitive is
actually this industry standard here in
upstate New York a variety called Sun
rich orange under short day conditions
it develops these ugly little Cypress
it's like super flowering whereas under
long day conditions it behaves itself
and looks just like you'd expect a
variety there's a close-up of the
budding over there on the right so it's
important to know whether a variety is
going to react that way or not and here
are some other characteristics then if
you take the short they sensitive
variety and this a test that we did in
in 2014 of newer varieties under short
day conditions at Florida in 50 days
took almost 70 days under long day
conditions right so the plants were were
speeded up quite a lot and as a result
plants were small and the flora diameter
was small as well for the day neutrals
not much difference between the two
treatments and the long day is reversed
to some extent flowers delayed under
short day conditions not so much under
long day etc etc so it can make quite a
bit of difference and it will make
difference for people who are using
to grow an early crop of sunflowers
because they're putting them in when
march/april when the day length is is
still short and so they're triggered and
you get early flowering that's great but
plants are like this and the plants are
ugly so you can't market it so it's
important to know or if you're growing
in Florida or South Carolina or
someplace then again you want to know
whether the plants are sensitive or not
last topic rudbeckia don't have an
example we aren't growing them this year
but very showy flowers I'll show you
some pictures little later on and we're
finding this is back 2005 that the later
you go in the season you plant them in
the spring they have very nice stems
they're no beautiful and so on but they
keep flowering all summer long which is
nice but the stem length gets shorter
and shorter and shorter wait a minute
what's going on here doesn't need
fertilizer or what's going on and then
we decided to look in the literature and
found out that it is an obligate
long-day plant but the way it reacts to
the day length requirement is not that
it stops flowering it sort of gradually
gets shortened it's as if the stem
length is dictated by the day length
under which the flower is developing so
we did some experiments with shading
trying to lengthen the stems and this
kind of thing didn't really make any
difference and you just have these
parallel lines all going down into the
basement so what to do how can we keep
stands long so we decided to innovate we
had to do it economically so have to
come up with instruments that can do
this for us without having to pay NYSEG
all sorts of fees because I mean if you
turn a flower field into a used car park
you do have electric bills that you
might
be able to really justify for a crop
like like rudbeckia here and so one
thing that we used is a light that
shines down on the plant and it has a
solar cell above its like things that
you see on sidewalks and things like
that to say hey that works pretty good
except that the amount of light that it
rose is relatively small and is focused
in the plants over here didn't get the
signal so they're still as short as
anything and in order to do the whole
bed you'd spend a fortune on it so that
didn't work then we got even more
innovative decided oh the way we can do
this is use Christmas lights right and
so again solar-powered you can get these
from Amazon no sweat and so they're
there you see the black string there and
you see the light shining down and you
see the plant saying me it's not enough
light it's really so so innovation
didn't work in this case and so we
decided we needed to really do a little
science in this and figure out well how
much light does it actually need in
order to trigger the photoperiod
response well we have this very nice
green house set up at Gutterman that we
were using for the photoperiod reaction
of sunflowers that i mentioned before so
we we can put curtains over the top and
just say okay the day lengths is when
the curtains close there's no more light
and so we use that and close the
curtains at 12 hours see the curtain
goes this way but then at the end we put
in these lights that kept the day length
at 16 hours so the long day and when you
do that and you only put lights at one
end then only the plants that are
actually sensing the light will flower
or have some kind of stem length and the
others own and so very nice
once close to the light are flowering
and looking very happy and these guys
down here are producing spinach but who
wants the Rebecca yes finish and and
from that then we can get an a a test of
how much light you really need and the
height of the flowers related to the day
length extension the intensity of light
of the day length extension shows that
it's about three micro moles per square
meter that's needed and so it does
really require the light equivalent to
what you'd have in a used car lot so
sorry we aren't going to be able to do
that so what to do instead well I think
what we have to go back to is the
germplasm of rudbeckia and try to find
varieties of rudbeckia that are a
neutral like some of the sunflower
varieties that we're working with before
no I'm not a reader and I run out of
time but if somebody looks looking for a
thesis project come and talk to me we'll
be happy to put you to work
so but if you take a variety like Indian
summer which is a very popular variety
under 12 hours no flowers under 16 hours
is doing what it should ok
so time for me to finish and so I'd like
to conclude its first of all to
summarize that in the cut flower
industry local cut flower industry in
the northeastern United States in this
in the state's general is increasingly
producing products that people want and
producing income for those people that
are growing the flowers and it's an
important one which i think really does
require quite a bit of back stopping as
they help themselves as well and the
association of specially cut flower
growers is that organization that's
helping them quite a lot supplying them
with research is something that I've had
the privilege to do and have enjoyed
very much and that is
gotten into some extension work as well
now I should have spent about half an
hour thanking people some of you in the
room many of you in the room and many
others in the department now section and
others who have been instrumental in
helping me work in this field and and
getting the job done the two that I want
to mention that are sitting in the front
here are Priscilla and Emily who have
put in long hours this year somehow and
after all the years of research I
haven't still haven't been able to
figure out how to grow only a few crops
I always say old man this looks good let
me put in a variety trial of that and
and they have been the suffering beasts
of burden that and have in fact spent
time to get them all harvested and
measure then things like that so I do
appreciate that and thank you very much
for that the farm managers the
greenhouse managers all their staff have
been essential in this work as well many
people in the department I really thank
everyone very very much and I especially
want to also mention Bill Miller and
Neil Matson who have had the privilege
to work with on some of this work it's
something that has really helped
tremendous tremendous mouths so thanks
everyone if there are questions
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu